with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to sum all so if you didn't see
using kubernetes spinnaker and Estia to
manage a multi cloud environment then
stay tuned because here's the rewind as
a business you don't want to put all of
your eggs into one cloud basket so it
makes sense to choose a multi cloud
strategy or maybe your developer and
your boss is telling you that you have
to go multi cloud
either way you're faced with the
challenges of managing workloads and
resources across on-premise and multiple
public clouds there are lots of benefits
to going multi cloud you have the
ability to optimize based on cloud
provider you have less lock-in and
better availability in case of any
downtime however all of these
differences means a complex environment
with diverse tools and capabilities
choice can lead to chaos and developers
just want the ability to use a service
ideally they can just describe something
they want and the resource shows up for
them abstraction is valuable to
developers so we can walk through how to
make some of these tools develop a multi
cloud approach to our application let's
demonstrate how to manage container
orchestration continuous integration and
deployment and a service mesh with this
focus of abstraction it's also important
to note that you can use any of your
existing tools and swap out for these
these fit well for multi cloud but you
can decide which are best for your
application starting with kubernetes you
can use this to coordinate your
containers in a consistent way this
means that you get to separate business
logic which is the code that runs the
important stuff from having to manage
the services which is how it runs in the
cloud this abstraction helps you focus
on describing how the workload should
behave and scale without needing to
worry about the platform or any hardware
specifics once your application can run
you'll need to manage deployments for
releasing new versions instead of
pushing out a new version to all of your
users at once you can use a canary build
to release it out to a limited number of
users and understand the impact in fact
there are a number of ways to manage
application deployment spinnaker gives
you application centric controls for all
stages of the application lifecycle you
can create pipelines to handle
deployments rolling updates version
tests and do smooth roll backs spinnaker
is open source and works with a variety
of extensions to fit into your lifecycle
management and workflows now that you've
got an application
running and updating smoothly across
multiple environments you need to make
sure that your business logic is
distracted from your network
functionality sto another community
driven open-source effort helps you
manage your application by doing exactly
that this builds on the theme from
before give app developers more time to
focus on core logic and abstract away
all the advanced networking by using Sto
you can configure communication between
services enforce security and resiliency
and monitor networking SDO is made up of
configurable components such as envoy
pilot mixer and citadel it's a lot to
take in but Amir does a fantastic job of
showcasing what these components do and
how they give you full control of your
application networking for smarter
routing higher resiliency strong policy
enforcement and observable metrics I
definitely recommend checking out the
walkthrough of is DEA's architecture for
more details if you'd like to see the
full talk check out the link in the
description below and don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more great next rewind content
thanks for watching
[Music]